[Music]
[Music]
when I was younger my mother once told
me Joey never approach a white main
Lionel with your weapon drone and at the
time I didn't know what she was talking
about but after making my way through
breath of the wild and its abundance of
dangerous monsters I finally understand
and I'm here to pass that information
down to you guys with this mini-boss
guide that will help you conquer some of
the bigger enemies of the game has in
store for you most of the mini bosses in
the game will drop a bunch of cool loot
so bring your finest weapons brush up on
your combat skills and check out our
cooking guide for the best stat boosts
because a hunting we will go don't be
fooled into hopping on top of these guys
for a better view the giant rock bodies
have the ability to take off a huge
number of hearts in just one blow
whether it's throwing its arms at you or
just body slamming you into dust but
find the growth on their bodies
typically located on the top of their
heads and look very similar to mining
nodes and then fire an arrow at it to
stun them then climb aboard and smash
that thing into pieces and if you're
having some trouble avoiding the rocks
they throw a couple of bombs should do
the trick the igneel and frost versions
of the taos will be a little bit
trickier though if you don't have the
right armor to protect yourself you
won't be able to stand on top of the
talus without gain burned or frozen so
use weapons of the opposite element to
stun them and then you can safely mount
their backs and wail on their weak spot
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya
[Music]
oh and don't forget to pick up all the
sweet gems they drop these sand
creatures are like the aliens from the
movie tremors step on the sand near them
and keep an eye out for that question
mark prompt hovering over their head in
order to stop their advance you'll need
to hop on anything that isn't sand so
hopefully there's a rock nearby because
the last thing you want is for them to
catch you the key for them is to lure
them to the surface so throw a sphere
bomb and let it roll around attracting
the mole Duga then wait for them to
emerge from the sand and eat the bomb
and then you can detonate it and stun
them for hits these sleepyheads will
usually keep to themselves unless of
course you come stomping all over their
territory but you don't always have to
kill them if you just want that key or
royal weapon hanging around their neck
consider creeping in at night or by the
mask of rain then activate some stealth
buffs and you can climb onto his belly
to take his belongings but in case you
do wake them up we've got a back-up plan
you're gonna want to shoot them where
else in as one eye to stun him once he's
down you can get some swings in before
he gets back up and do put some distance
between you and the he knocks because
it's old but stomp you into oblivion
but once you get them to half health
they'll start picking up on your tactics
and actually cover their weak spot when
you're aiming your bow so the key here
is to either use your upgraded stasis to
freeze him allowing you to get a couple
shots in or you can burn some grass
around them to create some lift and get
that slow-mo arrow shot
oh right in the pupil there's also a
cursed version of this guy known as the
stall Knox who only appears that night
he works in the same way as the he
knocks just watch out for flying bones
and shooting his eye will actually cause
it to pop out of its socket and flop
around on the floor for you to whip on
let's get this thing out of here and
finally there's the Lionel
the four-legged centaur dudes that pack
a mean punch despite being the strongest
out of all the mini bosses you're likely
to encounter them fairly early in your
adventure they come in an assortment of
colors and flavors starting with red for
the simple but will still kill you then
moving up to blue for the will
definitely kill you version and finally
topping it off with the white mane
Lionel otherwise known as the I'm just
gonna go that way but they're not
indestructible in fact a well-placed
arrow to the face will stun any Lionel
long enough for you to get some solid
hits in and if you got your upgrades
stasis room you can actually freeze them
in place before you unload a half a
dozen arrows into his skull stunning the
Lionel with the hedgehog will also allow
you to climb aboard his rear end and
attack him there the attacks you do
while mounting them will deal full
damage as well as causing no durability
loss to your weapons so equipped
whatever massive blade you've got in
your bag and swing away
so those are some of our best practices
when it comes to the mini-bosses in
breath of the wild I hope this video
makes your life in the game a little
less prone to death but if you've got
any tips for tackling these beasts
including the fabled Silvermane Lionel
please let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to the
GameSpot YouTube channel for even more
coverage of breath of the wild
[Music]
[Music]